okay so we have now come to the part
where we will create a new project for
App Engine you create new projects using
the developer console which can be
accessed at this URL this is a console
that allows you to configure many
different Google services but in this
course we will focus on the App Engine
specific parts go there and create a new
project we will talk about installing
the development environment a bit later
on so don't worry about that right now
while creating the project you will be
presented with the following dialog box
pay special attention to the project ID
the product ID must be unique and it has
certain naming restrictions having a
project ID are happy with though can be
quite handy since you can access your
application to a URL containing it after
you've created your project this is the
URL that you can use to access it so in
this example the final URL will become
HTTP colon slash slash apt - octagon -
five three three appspot.com
since the project ID was this so it's
now time for you to go and create your
new project